what's up everybody Zacky here with geek
culture and today we've got something a
little bit different now you know we've
covered video and photography and that's
more of Bobby's side but if geek culture
is to delve into streaming well this is
something special for us and perhaps you
guys as well this is the YOLO box Pro
it's also from the fox head YOLO live
they send this to us and they want us to
check this out now if you're streaming
like a multicam setup two camps three
camps or maybe more than three inputs
then this is supposedly the all-in-one
solution
to live stream and broadcast your
streaming session so let's check what
the YOLO box Pro is all about
to unbox this it's probably all the
manuals Pro user manual over here and a
quick guide now this is just a simple
screen protector that you install on the
YOLO box Pro this looks like a tablet oh
this is chunky
now as you can see
it's pretty thick it's not your ordinary
iPad okay this is some interesting piece
of tech we'll get back to that we will
soon here we have
what seems to be
a USB a to a USBC cable
we also have
a USBC to USBC cable and next we have
something interesting here
this is what looks to be it's a mount
for your camera and for a tripod we've
also got a set of tools here an allen
key as well as a SIM card ejector pin so
starting on this side these are
basically the ports we have the HDMI one
two and three we have a USB port an
ethernet port a HDMI out a USB type c
for other inputs and devices we've also
have a headphone jack mic in line in as
well as another USB C for charging this
device now if you flip it to the other
side you can see that there's an SD card
tray and a SIM card tray and here is the
power button now as I mentioned before
this YOLO box does have a SIM card tray
and it's also an Android device as long
as you have a 4G enabled SIM card you
can practically take this anywhere with
you and start live streaming
this is impressive all right you know so
I believe all we need to do is to
actually simulate a multi-cam production
live stream and play around with the
yellow box
Let's Do It Let's Do It All right so as
you can see we have
four devices plugged in into the YOLO
box right now we have our main camera
and our overhead cameras via a mini hdmi
to hdmi through the yellow box we've
also plugged in the USB webcam camera
and we've also managed to have an input
of our screen on this laptop so one two
three
oh nice transition fade and four
very very nice what I'm gonna do is
simultaneously record this session
so as you can see on the YOLO box itself
we have a nice monitor panel with an
overview of all four inputs again this
is totally touch screen so let's shift
over to the Logitech webcam
boom hello
wow
overhead cam
hello
and of course
our laptop
very interesting very very interesting
now there is a slight latency but it's
not too jarring so I really love that
now we have a few modules over here we
have overlays I believe there's
something to do with broadcast that's
grayed out for a moment we've also have
our audio monitoring and audio control
panel we have our scoreboard display
this is going to be interesting I
believe the next one is comments that's
also unavailable because we're not
streaming right now and we also have a
settings
now as we go through the settings we can
see that we are able to switch the way
we switch our video sources SD card
videos switching settings
interesting
SD card management we have a program Out
video Source transitions now this is the
place where we can actually configure
our transitions so I felt that the fade
was a little bit too long I'm going to
shrink it down to maybe 0.5 seconds and
let's try something else how about a
very cheesy Cube transition let's do
that all right so from our recording of
our screen go back to main cam
this oh man I love this
well try out the cross Zoom as well
that is
that's that's nice I like this
transition
it's great so let's try out the audio
now if let's just say you have one audio
source and our main audio Source here is
through our HDMI 2 I believe and it's
connected to our main cam with our
wireless mic setup
and when we choose automatic it's going
to jump between uh inputs and let's say
you have multiple audio sources and you
just want to pick one well you can
specifically highlight for instance HDMI
2.
and this will make sure that the main
audio from HDMI 2 is picked up I have to
say this makes everything very easy
there's no need to play around with a
bunch of cables or encoders or mixes
just to get your audio where you want it
to be now as you know let's check out
the scoreboard effect here so scoreboard
display on
nah wow cool we can change the team name
instead of the game name to FIFA World
Cup and and I've got to say the UI is
pretty responsive as well that's cute
team one
Zaki
team two
Zinio
right and we can you can even add logos
so I'm just gonna add a picture of Bobby
here I think we're ready to go with this
so I'm going to click done I'm going to
click a tick there so I think actually
having a scoreboard is actually pretty
interesting just imagine you're having
your own like game session or like a
kind of like an Esports session if you
will and if you need a scoreboard on the
Fly
this works see I even added a timer over
there and I can just update the
scoreboard as and when I want to
I just love how responsive this is man
that's cool that's pretty cool for
scoreboard display I think that's a very
smart movie yellow box give it also
saves time you know doing all this
scoreboards impose but I have to say you
know it would be nice if you could
animate in a sense that the scoreboard
comes in and out if you want in this
case the scoreboard is just going to
stay as is it is a bit of a learning
curve it will take some time for you to
orientate around the YOLO box but the UI
is so simple and easy to follow now on
to our overlays this is the part where
it gets interesting we have three
different choices we got image overlays
lower thirds and even a countdown timer
so let's start with image overlays
now here I have a few saved photos so
being the narcissistic person I am I'm
just gonna add images of myself so I can
really think of different scenarios like
for instance all right switch the can
too have you ever wanted to own your own
Zaki switch back to km1 well now you can
with your own Zaki
let's hear talking about a product that
hasn't been released that you've seen
those kind of videos right you could do
that you could also add your own lower
thirds now
the cool thing about it is that the YOLO
box itself has a few presets right here
so
dude let's just add our own man title
awesome host
and we're done with the overlays let's
take that here out of the way
and now and now that we've made our own
lower thirds you know I always wanted to
make my own commercial so I'm gonna try
and do this flawlessly as I can
switching to webcam
hello this is Zaki news reporter
reporting for Duty and I'm going to
report that the world is on fire
switching back to cam one that's four
day we have it guys your very own lower
thirds introduced the cast members
introduce your talents
whoever it may be into our live stream
on the go on the fly with the YOLO box
now if I want to take it away
I want to show you guys something this
is called a countdown timer now for this
countdown timer you have two options
they're completely customizable where
you can change the grading of colors but
honestly these animations look so slick
and fantastic already
right you can set a timer to 10 minutes
15 minutes an hour tops I guess yeah all
the way to an hour
we're just gonna go by default
and what it's gonna do simply
boom
there you have it guys
a countdown timer to preempt your
audience
all right no more fussing about your
third party software like OBS or xsplit
this YOLO box can do it for you now one
more thing that I did mess around with
is the ability for you to actually add
your own videos into the live stream
so before we continue
let me talk to you about today's sponsor
Logitech here at geek culture audio is a
huge part of our daily lives both work
and play so what's our choice of
headphones well meet the Logitech g435
Lightspeed wireless gaming headset it
allows you to listen to all the rich
sounds from your music videos and games
across PC console and mobile while
spotting some popping vibrant colors not
only that it weighs just 165 grams which
means sometimes you even forget that
you're wearing it with the robust
battery life of 18 hours you can enjoy
your gaming sessions for prolonged
periods of time for more details head
over to
logitechg.com alright so while exploring
the video Source features you can
actually add your own videos on top of
your live stream
so if let's just say you have a video
segment you want to introduce you can do
that and I already have something loaded
up I'm just gonna show it to you guys
Bobby back with you here to talk about
the Nikon zfc as a matter of fact I'm
recording this entire video on the Nikon
zfc 4k 24p on this and as you can see
you can actually do something like that
now the only problem I face is that
there's a green bar at the bottom this
footage is actually in 4k and the output
is at 1080p so bear in mind the videos
that you're going to load into the YOLO
box itself it should be 1080P and not 4K
and you won't have this problem
another cool feature when you add video
source is that you have three more
multi-view options which is picture in
picture video split view and side by
side that means you can technically do
two things simultaneously
so for top cam and our main cam I want
to see how split view works
so adding that I'm going to select HDMI
1 Click next HDMI 2
and Bing Bang Boom all right now we have
a few options in terms of how we want to
customize the border and the separator
so starting off with border thickness we
can make it real thick or as thin as we
want the separator the separator
position kind of helps us control the
bias
which is pretty cool
I don't like the stick in the middle I
think that's pretty scented now there's
there's no digits or numbers to kind of
gauge so you kind of have to go by feel
as you slide but
yeah we're kind of there
another cool thing is separator
Direction so on the bias you can
actually change how much of a split you
want it at an angle which is pretty cool
kind of like this
very modern very Urban once we're done
I'm gonna split view check that out this
is cool this is pretty pretty awesome I
love that the next video source that we
have under multi views is the picture
and picture video now this is
interesting say you are a streamer and
you're you're playing a video game on
your laptop and you also have a main cam
fixing you
can do both now you got to pick our main
screen that would be our laptop HDMI 3
and we also have our sub screen which
should be our let's say Logitech webcam
and there you go guys you can actually
bring the scale down of your
sub screen I'm going to put a lower
right corner I'm gonna make this one to
one so we can crop out unwanted space
I'm gonna bring this to the corner over
here
and boost the scale up just a wee bit
switch the picture and picture and hey
guys oh yes I'm a gamer oh games
FPS hurts
love it so you can see picture and
preacher mode works relatively smoothly
God I love this so much so last but not
least we do have the third video source
which is side by side now let's just say
you have a product showcase I want to
show two different things happen at the
same time it's kind of like a split
screen mode but with picture in picture
it's going to show you the full size of
both videos so let's just say I want to
select our overhead cam is Source One
and Main camera sauce too
and we can actually show two things at
the same time probably we can add a
background image which is quite
interesting I'm gonna just show a
background image of this
randomness
look at that
two things happening at the same time
what is spacing let's play around with
that ah okay I'm gonna make it this
big as possible
and side by side three two one boom this
is a possibility that you guys would
like to explore or a product showcase if
I'm talking to this camera and I want to
show the yellow box that can be possible
so man
this is endless you can do so much
and right now throughout this whole
session we are only at half the battery
so you can expect about
an hour two hours worth you can have it
charged while using it there's no issue
with that so yeah I think that covers
pretty much it for monitor View
let's jump out of this all right so we
can see that we already have a session
for our live stream so let's go ahead
and open it we have a platforms model
and this is where you can actually link
up your YouTube live account your
Facebook Live account Twitch account you
can even add your own custom rtmp link
say you're live streaming a graphic
intensive game and on top of that you're
running a third-party application such
as xsplit or OBS now you're gonna
experience some sort of performance drop
and you don't want that so having a
dedicated device to do that broadcasting
and live streaming for you is going to
help you tremendously now as a live
streamer it's also important to engage
with your audience and the good thing
here is that you do have a comments page
so you can actually reply to your
audience's comments now it does disclaim
that the comments are only supported for
Facebook and YouTube right now and it
will only display the first hundred
comments which are I would say it's it's
plenty enough for me now the live stream
quality is going to be set by default to
1080p but you can choose to have it 720p
or even 480p if you will now on top of
that this is a cool part if you go into
the settings menu and you click
streaming mode
you can also use yellow lights
multi-streaming service now this is
going to help you stream through three
different platforms so let's say a
twitch user you want to show it on
YouTube live as well as Facebook live
you can do it simultaneously which is
super awesome
now for those of you who are really into
the technical side of streaming you can
also play around with the encoding
settings we got CBR CQ and vbr we can
even change the frame rate and the bit
rate now for the FPS here the max FPS is
30 and not 60 unfortunately but this
sort of gives you a bit of flexibility
when it comes to customizing your
encoding settings so definitely do check
it out so that covers the YOLO box Pro
as you can tell there are already tons
of options for you to customize your
live stream so you're already getting a
solid companion for your live stream
production an incredible live service
from YOLO live so if you really think
about it this device is doing the job of
six people and even more we are talking
about live stream solutions for
marketing real estate non-profit cooking
corporate and you know worship centers
and even funerals so are you gonna pick
up the YOLO box Pro or if you have any
questions do let us know down in the
comments below and while you're down
there do give us a like And subscribe
till then this is Zaki signing off
[Music]